pour avoir causé la mort de son épouse
eric desnoues encourt la perpétuité si
les jurés valide l'homicide volontaire
sur conjoint ou alors 20 ans si c'est la
thèse des violences volontaires ayant
entraîné la mort sans intention de la
donner qui est retenue dilemme difficile
pour les jurés
compte tenu de l'absence de preuves dans
le dossier c'est précisément parce qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir d'éléments matériels
qui met en difficulté la thèse de
monsieur dénoue que l'accusation s'est
acharné pour le lui faire payer
c'est à dire que l'on vient faire payer
un homme d'avoir fait disparaître un
corps parce que ça lui était absolument
insupportable ce gore symboliser son
forfait et par conséquent en l'absence
de preuves on va lui faire payer un
comportement pour les avocats des
parties civiles
eric desnoues aurait tué françois
s'affairent dans l'appartement et non
pas en la bousculant dans l'escalier
il l'aurait tué pour la remplacer au
domicile conjugal par sa maîtresse et
aurait également volé son argent et ses
bijoux
pire encore pour les avocats des parties
civiles il aurait tenté de maquiller son
geste en crimes sexuels on va la
retrouver complètement nue dans la forêt
à même le sol et elle va être laisser
comme ça et en partie dévorée par les
bêtes on est sûr que celui qui vous
voulez que ce soit même sans preuve
matérielle
les jurys peuvent rendre leur décision
sur la base de leur intime conviction
le verdict est attendu dans la soirée